[Musique]
voici le cobas le nouvel employé du
chute québec qui ne passe pas inaperçu
d'abord parce que c'est un robot de la
taille d'une voiture mais aussi parce
qu'il peut analyser jusqu'à 1000 tests
de kobe de 19 en un temps record le plus
vite plus vite qu'on peut avoir c'est
environ trois heures donc c'est quand
même rapide mais l'avantagé principal
est sévère et là c'est vraiment d'avoir
une grande cadence donc sont capables de
travailler 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur
7 avec moins de besoins en ressources
techniques pour le docteur jean longtin
microbiologiste-infectiologue l'arrivée
de 10 machines cobas dans les
laboratoires du québec a grandement
augmenté la capacité de dépistage le 6
janvier par exemple plus de quarante
trois mille prélèvements ont été
réalisés
ils réussissent aussi à détecter les
variantes du virus donc on passe à la
troisième phase partout dans le monde
les scientifiques les ont adoptées le
ministère de la santé en a commandé six
autres pour un total de 16 appareils
l'automatisation et la vos cotisations
des laboratoires étaient dans les plans
du ministère depuis quelques temps avant
même la bible la copie de 19 à peut-être
été l'élément déclencheur qui a accéléré
7 millions de dollars ont été dépensés
pour l'achat des seize robots mais
l'économie en ressources humaines est
inestimable selon le docteur longtemps
les personnes qui font les analyses
manuellement ça prend beaucoup de temps
prend beaucoup de ressources puis ils
vont nous équipes commencent à être
fatigués quand la pandémie sera derrière
nous le cobas n'aura pas fini son
travail pour autant il sera utilisé pour
d'autres maladies infectieuses hiv ou le
dépistage du cancer du col de l'utérus
par exemple le seul grain de sable dans
l'engrenage du cobas c'est le suivant le
ministère de la santé nous informe que
pour fonctionner il a besoin de réactifs
plus dispendieux que tous les pays
s'arrache encore aujourd'hui ici
véronique prince radio canada québec